Людина — один із видів,
який населяє планету Земля.
Є й інші види, які також мають право на життя.
Заповідник — це свого роду резервація для дикої природи.
Це невеличкий клаптик, невеличке місце,
яке ми залишаємо для того,
щоб могли також зберегтися і інші види,
інші форми життя.
Ми не одні живі істоти, крім нас є ще інші.
Подобаються вони нам чи не подобаються.
Потрібні вони нам чи не потрібні.
Вони є і теж хочуть жити.
«Канівський заповідник» — один із найстаріших в Україні.
Уже незабаром буде 100 річчя від його створення.
Зараз ми знаходимся в південній частині острова
Шелестін Канівського природного заповідника.
Тут багато водоплавних птахів,
особливо під час міграції.
Такі, ну чомусь так назвали,
затишне місце, закрите з усіх боків.
З моєї точки зору як орнітолога,
це одна з найцікавіших ділянок заповідника.
Тому що тут є, на що подивитись.
Птахів, що залишаються на зимівлю, з 1987-ого року,
скільки я тут працюю, 37 видів уже зареєстровано.
І досить багато з них, дев'ять,
занесено в Червону книгу України.
10, 11...
Тут, на цьому дереві, 11 гнізд.
Коли ми робимо облік, ми пересікаємо острів
і рахуємо гнізда на кожному дереві.
І я на планшетці одразу записую.
Ух, зараза.
Просто ходиш і тебе обстрілюють.
А сам ти тихенько рахуєш.
Ну і потім я записую все одразу в планшет.
Ось видно, чому, чому всихають дерева.
Листя повністю заляпане послідом.
Послід у бакланів дуже їдкий.
Тобто листя просто всихає, вимирає.
Тому в таких місцях витримують ті дерева, які швидко ростуть.
Наприклад верба, ясенелистий клен.
Так виглядає процес відмокання після того,
як все це порахуєш.
При тому ароматик...
Проходиться весь острів отакими зиґзаґами методично.
Потім уже стоїш, відмокаєш і чекаєш,
поки приїде човен і забере.
Як утворилися ці острови?
Коли затоплювали водосховище,
то там були пагорби, далеко від Дніпра.
Лівобережна Борова тераса, так звана.
Ну, а коли затопили, то вони стали островами.
Заповідник — це місце, де природа живе так,
як їй хочеться, за своїми законами.
І ми не втручаємося в її життя.
А приходимо тільки до неї в гості і
лише в строго обмежених масштабах.
Тільки по окремих стежках.
А так ми їй не заважаємо.
Це її дім, її територія.
Птахи, що їм не роби, залишаються
такими, якими вони є.
Можна спробувати знайти з ними
спільну мову, можна приручити.
Але не зробиш ти з ворони орла, чи з орла качку.
Познайомились... Можеш розказати як ми познайомились.
Вона була на практиці в Канівському заповіднику,
це був другий курс, вірно?
Я була на другому курсі і мені треба було взяти павутинку.
Сітку для відлову птахів.
От я і прийшла просити,
бо не вистачало однієї сіточки.
Я прийшла до Віталія, от так і познайомилися.
Потім були експедиції...
Заходить таке перелякане дитя,
каже: «Можна ту сітку».
[сміються]
Природа зблизила.
Два непосидючих персонажі.
Це точно. Яке їхало, таке й здибало.
Пісня у птахів не передається генетично.
Вона передається навчанням.
Так як у людини: набір звуків дитина
може видавати різний,
але мова має бути вивченою.
Точно так і у зябликів пісня вивчається.
Я займаюся зябликами, їх тут повно.
Що цікаво, з року в рік —
двадцять років я за ними спостерігаю.
Вони займають постійно одні і ті ж території.
А комплекс пісень залишається стабільним.
Ми аналізували комплекси пісень.
І з наших досліджень виплило,
що вони зберігаються протягом всього часу
з останнього зледеніння,
тобто двадцять тисяч років.
[спів зяблика]
Співають переважно самці.
Їхня ідея така: «Іди геть з моєї території, я тут живу.
А ти, дівчино, йди до мене, будь ласонька,
подивись, який я гарненький».
Все дуже просто і прагматично.
Що це було?
Отам чорноголова кропив'янка.
А тут була якась «розборка» між птахами, якийсь скандал.
Тут є на що подивитися,
до чого призводить вирубування лісів.
Там, де рельєф, особливості геологічної будови
сприяють розмиванню ґрунтів.
На Канівщині такий милий антирекорд:
найглибші в Європі яри.
Це зумовлено і тим,
що складна геологічна будова регіону,
крутий нахил гір, м'які ґрунти.
І видно до чого може дійти.
Яка глибина яру і це ще далеко
не найглибший яр біля Шівського.
Мова людини має діалекти і у птахів є те саме.
При чому дуже подібне.
І вивчення територіальних комплексів,
діалектів, субдіалектів — це, фактично,
ідеальна модель для аналізу мови
людської, змін людської мови.
У птахів пісня не передається спадково,
вона завчається.
Втрата цієї інформації, тобто якщо птахи втрачають
ці записи, — це втрата назавжди.
Це так як буде втрачена мова,
яка не має письменності.
І навіть якщо говорити про мову,
ми можемо прочитати, що написано.
Але ми не знаємо, як воно звучало.
Ми не знаємо навіть,
як говорили наші предки.
От вимова, нюанси ці втрачаються.
І втрачаються назавжди.
У птахів, та й загалом у тварин,
це взагалі набагато більш жорстко,
оскільки мову їх ніхто не записує.
Наша, ми називаємо, лучно-степова ділянка, тут.
Ну, власне, воно все заростає лісом.
Ось цю сосну я пам'ятаю от-такенькою.
Віталій її обкопував від пожеж.
І он, яка красунечка виросла.
Була б боревітром, сама б тут політала.
Не так давно, всього три десятки років тому, ці землі,
посередині між заповідним лісом, розорювалися.
Зараз як ми бачимо, тут лучно-степова ділянка.
Слідів від коліс немає, пішов ліс.
Від тієї пустелі, яка тут була під час
сільськогосподарської діяльності,
ми перемістилися наче в інший вимір.
Вимір, де все буяє, все цвіте, безліч рослинності.
Тобто там, де мінімум впливу людини,
починається відновлення всього середовища.
Ми стоїмо на самій Мар'їній горі,
в центрі Канівського заповідника.
І звідси відкривається вид на
Велике Скіфське городище.
Це заповідна гора, там було розкопано
поселення скіфів-землеробів.
А трішки дальше, ми бачимо Канівське водосховище.
Водосховища, фактично, знищили —
те прадавнє Дніпро, яке завжди бачили.
Знаєте, неможливо жити без вітру у волоссі,
без співу птахів.
І не хочеться втратити те, що у нас є.
Цей світ чарівний, врешті-решт, це — свобода.
Вибір завжди залишається:
залишається можливість привертати увагу.
І ми намагаємось все ж робити
не через зло, а через позитив.
Тобто створювати відношення любові,
тепла, а не заборон.
Бо якщо будуть кричати «не можна»,
то це викличе зворотню реакцію.
Захочеться залізти, нагадити, поламати.
А якщо показати наскільки воно ніжне,
наскільки воно вразливе, наскільки воно красиве,
тоді є надія, що про це просто замисляться.
Дедалі більше молодих канівчан.
Дорослі «свинячать».
А молоді приїхали відпочити,
то спочатку прибрали,
згребли все і потім все вивезли з собою,
щоб не залишати сміття.
Тобто у них вже є певні закладені стереотипи
поведінки дружньої до природи
Вони вже не мають бажання забруднювати, нищити.
І якусь певну, дуже таку обережну надію нам дає.
Що можливо наша безнадійна справа небезнадійна.
Що майбутнє у нас таки є.
Комарів достатньо погодували?
Ну це біотехнічний захід — підгодівля комарів.
Їх потім з'їдять пташки наші улюблені.
Їм буде дуже гарно, пташкам.